[Music]
beth is with us in houston texas hey
beth welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hey what's up
hey hey i have a wonderfully awesome
problem
okay i like those
yeah yeah okay so just a little
foundation our house has paid off we
have saved for retirement
we have savings to get to for an
emergency we have no debt and we have
three kids that we have five 29's for
um the oldest one is 20 21 the second
one is 20 years old and then the baby is
18 years old so i have two in college
and one that's a senior
and the two in college we have managed
to cash flow all their college education
so far
because they had wonderful scholarships
and they we knew that they were probably
going to go on to secondary graduate
school um the oldest one just got
accepted to dental school so in the fall
she'll be doing that thank god
they're killing it girl wow
yeah we we planned ahead you got it
going on yeah
but so now what's happened though my
wonderful problem is are my in-laws i
gave the kids money
for
for them but they they gave them ten
thousand dollars each
and our kids being responsible you know
they're going to listen to us for what
we say we should do with this money and
of course we want to save it for their
education so
more so i thought education was covered
well
it what we have saved probably won't get
the oldest two through
like that's not going to get them
through dental school the oldest one
wants to go to dental school she's been
accepted the second one wants to go to
medical school she's got a 4-0 in
college so i bet she will be able to go
yeah and so that we have about 66 000
and 529 per kid
yeah and that's not going to get them
through four years of dental and medical
school yeah just drop it in the for drop
it in the 529. it's only 10 grand he
thinks
yeah you think just dump it all in all
at once stagger it in or should we just
just drop it in there just drop it in
there you're going to be using it
shortly it's not going to be in there
that long
well that's what i thought it should
instead of putting it in there and then
pulling it right out should that first
semester for the oldest child just write
it out the checking account it's fine if
you want to do that it's nothing bro no
problem either way it is gr whatever
growth it gets if it's however long it's
in there is going to be tax-free if you
drop it in the 529 that's the only
benefit but it's not going to grow that
much if it doubled it'd only be ten
thousand dollars
yeah so it's not you know if you just
use it for that first semester that's
fine too
but yeah definitely lay it on the
education label without a doubt because
you got a lot of education bills still
coming
and um so if you want to run it through
the 529 and let it sit there a little
while use some of the 529 money that's
been in there a while that's fine but
it's six and one half dozen other it's
still going to work out about the same
there's not a long timeline here so it's
not like it's going to have 10 years to
grow so like dave's saying right
i'd be making a plan to try to cash flow
dental school medical school all of that
considering you guys are debt-free
you've got some sharp kids that aren't
afraid to work aren't afraid to get
scholarships so it can be done and i
can't wait to hear you call us back and
say we sent all three kids debt-free
medical school dental school it can be
done wow that'll be cool
that's a bill right there whew
yeah we're biting it off here man this
is big this is big but yeah that i think
you may just go ahead and use it just
dump it in the checking account like you
said use it use this 10 000 for the next
next check that comes up and then just
keep rocking but george is right pan
back and let's get together a full plan
you all have done such a great job beth
getting to this point
uh i would hate to look up and each one
of them have 400 thousand dollars in
medical school and dental school debt at
the end of the story after you got this
far and did a great job so
be very aware that all medical schools
are not equal
in quality nor in cost
and they're not necessarily correlated
same thing with dental schools and
honestly some of the dental schools are
absolutely insane
you should never go there based on what
they cost i just thought of the barred
future documentary with our our buddy
who took out a million dollars got a
million dollars in debt and he's an
orthodontist orthodontist